or stéphane guillon bonsoir alors
arrivées de lembras plus bas il paraît
qu'on a plus loin d'embrasser mais j'ai
eu
moi aussi je lui envoie
on sait bois aussi tous les 15 ans oui
on va c'est raté comme ça non nombreux
rappels
c'est en place et est ce que vous êtes
embrasser ou est ce que tu lui à laver
le palais
parce qu'il ya deux choses différentes
en fait parce que concrètement on avait
des vidéos on lutte là c'est plus la
vidéo a duré une minute rend
complètement là ils allaient dans ton
dos dopage il a fait un test pcr tout à
coup la ville ont répondu à l'avis de
goz l'atmosphère ce matin et électriques
[Applaudissements]
attention à fait gaffe en ouvrant
les mains pour tous après marie jo cette
femelle en chaleur
merci françois mais ça fait du bien de
se reconnecter à l'essentiel à la nature
arrêtons les divisions 1 et nous nous
vivons ça mais c'est vrai que ces
bateaux et mon bilan cela blé mission
officielle sur facebook pourra créer un
géraldine vous savez qu'on a informé des
coupes comme ça oui des jeunes filles et
des hommes qui sont venus dans les
missions qui nous ont dit moi je suis
célibataire je cherche le grand amour on
transmet tous les messages vous promet
il ya toujours des messages de pervers
dedans je préfère vous le dire parce que
ça c'est la vie mais vous faites le tri
1 après un regard du goût il fait 1
la note de séduction il offre une
feuille à marie jo et ça fait son effet
[Musique]
compilé chalon
quand les chaînes explorer les animaux
totems chose jamais vue en télé trans
fois pourquoi
quoi y'a pus de musique
et c'est passé
oui au moment où je reviens son plateau
sur la seconde partie
on la baisse un petit peu au fur à
mesure mais à la fin il me reste le
texte
on commence par toi
galanterie oblige aubry
alors qu'un bond au galop trio bris
[Applaudissements]
car
est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut régler le
dentier s'il vous plaît ça s'appelle la
tronçonneuse du rire et pour cela je
vais demander à la salle de démarrer la
tronçonneuse avec moi je vais tirer
imaginer une tronçonneuse et je vais
tirer sur le lanceur je vais tirer
quatre fois elle démarrera à la
quatrième fois et la première fois il
faut faire hahaha si vous voulez on y va
tensions et les attentions
[Musique]
molière pour moi est un homme
extraordinaire il est le fondateur du
théâtre tel que nous l'aimons il est un
grand chef de troupe il est un metteur
en scène incroyable il était paraît-il
d'après certains témoignages ils étaient
1 c'est mademoiselle poissons notamment
qu'il nous dit qu'il était un comédien
génial qu'avec simplement le jeu de ces
sourcil il était capable de faire
éclater une salle de rimeize il n'était
pas écrivain mais il n'était pas écrit
jean louis chautemps
pompiers sont venus
marcher sur un chemin de terre
où
la différence entre plaisir et bonheur
c'est au fond que le bonheur c'est une
sorte de plaisir mentaliser intériorisé
savourer est allé dans la durée et cette
société qui nous pousse à consommer tout
de suite à satisfaire nos plaisirs à ne
plus tolérer la frustration c'est une
société qui nous offrons beaucoup de
plaisir mais est-ce qu elle nous
rapproche du bonheur ça c'est une grande
question ce transgenres femme n'a pas du
tout apprécié qu'on l'appelle monsieur
non j'ai dit les gars en général juste
avant tu avais dit monsieur mais
monsieur espèces élu je viens dehors si
tu m'appelles encore monsieur je vais te
montrer ce que c'est qu'un homme excusez
moi
excusez moi
selon la loi new yorkaise ce vendeur
pourrait encourir une amende allant
jusqu'à 250 mille dollars maintenant on
est dans une société où les personnes
qui sont belles en plus davantage aux
personnes qui sont moins belle il faut
pas se voiler la face donc voilà c'est 2
pour pas pour autant que la chirurgie
esthétique et les salles de sport comme
je suis aujourd'hui existe voilà c'est
pas pour rien une des obsessions de la
course et pourtant d'avoir les dents
blanches pour cela on est prêts à
utiliser n'importe quoi même de l'uriné
car elle est acide et donc décapante
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer le résultat
n'est pas vraiment concluant
au xviie siècle on allait donc
complètement pourri avec des caries et
même parfois des verts or à l'époque et
il n'y a pas de dentiste j'ai fait le
nez une première fois mais comme j'étais
trop jeune par le cartilage a repoussé
parce que je les fais trop tôt j'ai pas
écouté le chirurgien est donc le carnage
a repoussé et ma bosse est revenu donc
jules refaire une deuxième fois cette
fois ci je les fais au laser et là il
est tout neuf il a dû jour je vous
présente s'appelle richard
j'ai fait les seins alors donc c'est
fatima et zorra et ils ont des prénoms
parce que c'est des êtres à part entière
et ils sont très heureux de vivre avec
moi d'ailleurs les siennes taubira dans
votre livre des pin souvenez-vous mère
agnès vous disais savez-vous christiane
que l'orgueil est un péché capital qui
peut devenir péché mortel inclusive
m'accuser vous des travailleuses
monsieur de la non je me rappelle de
cette ligne quand on sait immense je dis
bien l'immense quantité de pièces
comédie et tragédie que corneille a
produite mais non mais qu'est ce que ce
raisonnement et qu'est ce que c'est que
ce réseau a été un échec le misanthrope
a été un échec sont deux chefs-d'oeuvre
totaux mai mais de quoi on parle oui
c'est parce qu'ils lui c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on dit c'est est ce que au xviie
siècle et qui le torde le plus éloigné
dit bonjour
la manche n a pas tout raconter
mécréants demi faut
pas se lancer ce gars est plus difficile
que de dire bonjour ça je suis bien
d'accord pour voir
leur voix est une conclusion formidable
merci infiniment un clair merci à vous
alors normands ont tiers la petite
phrase qui fait du bien mais bon on a
pris le temps plutôt pour la méditation
je présente à nouveau votre livre sun
dancer aux éditions donc si vous avez
passé un agréable moment avec lui